I think it's just a really great you
know message for young girls Thank You
next Thank You Hannah Lux Davis the 32
year old director who along with ariana
grande masterminded the singer's most
recent music video jam-packed with
deliciously nostalgic references to our
favorite early 2000s rom-coms
[Music]
they've shattered YouTube and VEVO
records now Hannah is spilling the tea
on all the behind-the-scenes secrets
[Music]
she's talking about people she's dated
in the past are you working with her on
are we gonna decide what to write in the
book together how did you decide to kind
of bring all that to life from the jump
on the video we didn't want anything
negative everything had to be positive
and like grateful and like really what
this song is about and so we wanted to
make sure that even in the burn book it
wasn't a burn book it was a thank you
next book yeah yeah you definitely took
another yeah she definitely like made it
personal to her and that's again where I
feel like everybody's connecting with it
and like the like oh you know cuz it's
like it's very much it's what she would
write in her life in this character ah
great dancer time jobs okay like you
know what I mean like that for
handwriting yeah she really wrote all
that I wrote all this I thought
everything was huge her I do totally she
was like oh whatever II were like huge I
just cut off you know we're all like
yeah she's really smart she's really
funny as a director
how did Kris Jenner do what kind of
direction are you giving her when you're
on set Christian was a pro she like
knows what she's doing yeah like she's
definitely she was fearless
she knew that like this role was fun and
like she was very much on board to be
silly and not take herself too seriously
and she got right into the role so fast
she was really great with improv thank
you next [ __ ] we got to talk about
Jennifer Coolidge how did that come to
fruition that was through diem she was
so fun and just like hearing her stories
about like what it was actually like
filming Legally Blonde with like unreal
she was like we had no idea but like it
was just so much fun I'm like Reese was
so good like she was like really just
like she was just so good on camera like
we all knew that like she was really
special and so but like we had no idea
that it was gonna be such like an iconic
film they were making like back then it
was really cute yeah and it was it was
really big mm-hmm well I've only gone
out with one guy that had a big front
tooth
just sort of gave them talking points in
terms of what they'd be discussing in
the nail salon that was improvised oh
yeah Wow yeah Ariana was like the first
take of that Ariana laaser did you have
any idea what that conversation what
that dialogue was gonna be before you
got behind the camera we had a
conversation before the take and we were
just like spitballing like I don't know
like one time this thing happened to me
and like you know stories like that and
and we were just like Cyd million I
think I got it okay have you ever gone
out with someone that had no teeth at
all you know can I ask which movies you
guys discussed possibly doing that
didn't make it into the video and it was
the backstage moment before the Santa
dance window like trying to make fetch
happen but also like the lip gloss like
that although with that Victoria's
Secret lip gloss like oh my god and like
it's like station like iconic moment
like I guess remember as girls being
like that lip there's lips there was
never enough it was never enough and her
and I were very much like on the same
page like the lip gloss and and even a
my breakdown like for the in the first
ad of like what was in the scene I was
like there was just no time in that
shooting day
there's just the back of a girl wearing
a white dress mm-hmm what's that Ariana
no it wasn't it wasn't it was actually
our office manager at London Allie our
production company we she looks like
ariana grande late she has the same
build and coloring and we were gonna
start the process of like looking for an
Ariana devil but without even really ah
should we just like try and find
somebody and meanwhile every day we walk
into the office and we were looking at
one
so Ariana and never tried on a wedding
dress no that wasn't her did you borrow
any props or any wardrobe pieces nothing
funny you're rejecting everything on
Ariana was made specifically for her
okay her stylist law is like obviously
fantastic and then we had a really great
stylist for our cast and Marie anything
on Jennifer and everybody originals oh
yeah all original things were there
people that you guys reached out to for
possible cameos that wanted to do it
couldn't do it on our wish list
there was somebody Warner from Legally
Blonde yeah Matt Damon yeah yeah Matt
Davis and he was unavailable but I think
it was special creating our like a new
take on what that person would be like
the Kris Jenner sure a new cool mom
right you know you didn't go out to Amy
Poehler no it was like let's do our
version of a 20 I mean Amy Poehler's
Poehler's like a goddess yeah like we
obviously would have loved that but like
we wanted to put an ariana grande spin
on everything and I feel like at 2018
spin not only is the thank you next
video a massive pop-culture moment for
fans it was also a career-defining
experience for Ariana and Hannah
Jennifer Coolidge here today was
we had a fitting orianna's house and
Jennifer tried on all the outfits and it
was that was like Ariana were just like
oh my god it's Tanner cool it was cool
being with her as she was starstruck by
someone just like oh my god and then and
then later she was like this is the
coolest thing being a pop star has ever
allowed me to do with this video like
bringing all these ideas and people
together of just like her childhood
[Music]
I could just feel the crew being like
this is insane
like this is so sorry really big moment
yeah it felt really cool and like I I
had this moment with Brian and Scott our
Ghana's choreographers we just like
looked at each other like holy like it's
like like the most insane like moment of
my career
[Music]